And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
And oh, oh, oh
I slip through your fingers
And I call your name
Friday.
April 7th at 7 p.m. right here in this building.
We're going to join together with Pleasant Valley United Methodist Church.
That's the church that meets here on Sunday mornings.
And I love the moments where we can join together with them
and worship with them.
And Good Friday is a service you will not want to miss.
I mean, Easter's great, but Easter doesn't have the same punch
if you're not also thinking about Good Friday
and then the Saturday in between.
It's part of the whole arc of the story.
And then, you guys ready for Easter Sunday?
No. Nope.
It's in April.
Yeah, it's another month or so.
We are going to do something different and fun for Easter Sunday.
You ready for this?
8 a.m. service.
Woo-hoo!
Yes.
That is early.
No.
Laughter
Yep.
8 a.m.
8 a.m. Sunday service.
It's going to be right here.
Right here in this building.
Listen up for the details, okay?
Guess what?
You can wear your pajamas to Easter service if you want.
Yeah.
So we're going to give you something for getting here at 8 a.m.
It's going to be a beautiful, beautiful service.
And I, honestly, I've always wanted to attend an early service on Easter.
I never have.
And so I'm glad that we get to do that this year
because I can't think of a better way to celebrate Easter
than being with my favorite people early in the morning.
It just sounds like a great way to kick off that day,
to just from the get-go center on Jesus,
to remember the Easter story and to be together.
And so please, please join us.
8 a.m. I promise you.
It'll be worth it.
It'll be worth that early wake-up.
We will have coffee.
We'll have coffee for you.
We'll have tea.
We'll have a continental breakfast.
And you can wear your pajamas if you want.
You can dress very casual.
But it will be a beautiful, beautiful service.
Yes.
Yep.
So let's take a moment just to arrive here.
That was a lot of information.
You're probably still thinking about stuff from today, the week,
what's going on the week ahead.
This is a place for you to just be.
So let's take a moment.
Close your eyes.
Take a deep breath in.
Let it out.
One more time.
Breathe in.
Breathe out.
Let's pray.
God, thank you.
Thank you for today.
Thank you for all the ways you're in this day with us,
from the struggles to the joys to the annoyances to the beauty.
God, thank you that all beauty is yours,
the beauty in creation and nature,
beautiful days like today,
the beauty in people.
And God, I thank you for this community.
I thank you for everybody here.
Thank you for those watching online, God.
I pray your blessings over them,
that each one of us would know how loved we are
and that that love from you, God, is unconditional
and that, Jesus, you are with us no matter what we're going through,
that your love is with us, your presence is with us,
your grace is with us.
And God, help us to really be present tonight,
to be open for the things that you have for us
through the music, through the words,
through the people that are here, God.
It's such a beautiful orchestration of your love and your grace.
And I thank you, God, for the Easter story,
for the cross, for the things that seem bad but are really good,
for the ways that you turn ashes into beauty
and into redemption, into glory.
So, God, help us to hold on to those things,
to embrace them, to embrace you, God, tonight.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen. Thanks, Karen.
Well, would you guys stand with us?
We're going to enter into the worship section of our service.
But I was just reminded today, as we get going,
I just quickly wanted to throw this out.
I don't know what traditions you guys have come from,
but for me, I've always been a part of kind of a non-denominational,
evangelical-type tradition.
And I've been in either in the audience or on stage
for some very big, large, extravagant smoke-and-lights worship settings
that have been very powerful in moments.
So I'm not speaking down to those at all.
And then I've been a part of very quaint, small,
just a few people in a room with a guitar settings
that have also been very powerful.
And today, right before I came up on this stage,
I was unseating a toilet and putting on a new toilet.
And do you know what might have been the most worshipful thing I experienced?
It was my dad giving up his Sunday afternoon nap to come
and literally put his hand down in our nasty,
insert whatever word you want, toilets,
to put on a new one.
And it was just this reminder to me that worship is not the room that we're in
and it's not the music that we sing,
but it is the way that we have lived our lives.
It's the way that we interact with one another.
It's the love that we share with God and each other.
So regardless of our setting or how big or small the band,
how quality or unquality the music,
our worship is what we do with it.
And so I pray that today we will enter in with whatever's going on in our life
and find God right there in the midst of it,
because He is.
He is right there waiting for us.
So you guys are welcome.
With all of our stuff, we're all welcome to this space.
So let's enter into it together.
Kaitlyn's going to lead this first song.
It's called Crowded Table, and it's by the High Women.
And if you guys haven't heard it officially before,
you should look it up later because they have a really fun version,
and Kaitlyn does a pretty great job too.
♪♪♪
You can hold my hand when you need to let go
I can be your mountain when you're feeling badly low
I can be your streetlight showing you the way home
If you can hold my hand when you need to let go
I want a house with a crowded table
And a place by the fire for everyone
Let us take on the world while we're young and able
And bring us back together when the day is done
If we want a garden, we're going to have to sow the seeds
Plant a little happiness, let the roots run deep
If it's love that we give, then it's love that we reap
If we want a garden, we're going to have to sow the seeds
Yeah, I want a house with a crowded table
And a place by the fire for everyone
Let us take on the world while we're young and able
And bring us back together when the day is done
The door is always open, your picture's on my wall
Everyone's a little broken, yeah, everyone belongs
Yeah, everyone belongs
Oh, I want a house with a crowded table
And a place by the fire for everyone
Let us take on the world while we're young and able
And bring us back together when the day is done
Yeah, bring us back together when the day is done
Good job. All right, kiddos, y'all are dismissed to go to your classrooms.
Thanks for singing with us.
We're going to move into the prayers of the people.
And just like that song was just kind of talking about,
one of the values at the table is to be communal.
And there is room for us to carry each other's burdens.
And so as we bring our request to the prayers of the people,
I just encourage you to share what it is that's on your heart in this space
and let us hold that for you together before God.
Would you guys read this aloud with me?
For the city of Sachse, Texas, and for every city and community
and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth that you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and orphan,
for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives and all who remember and care for them,
we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized, and those unjustly targeted
for their gender, sexuality, race, or other perceived difference,
we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection,
and for those struggling with mental and emotional health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that you hear us,
so we lift these names and situations up to you.
Johnny Owen and Charles C.
Jennifer.
Lauren.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope,
peace, and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
You're the resurrection that we've waited for.
You buried the night and came with the morning.
You're the king of heaven.
The praise is yours.
The longer the quiet, the louder the chorus.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
We will sing a new song because death is dead and gone with the winter.
We will sing a new song.
Let hallelujahs flow like a river.
We're coming back to life.
We're reaching towards the light.
Your love is like springtime.
You're the living water.
God, we thirst for you.
The dry and the barren will flower in bloom.
You're the sun that's shining.
You restore my soul.
The deeper you call us, oh, the deeper we'll go.
We will sing a new song because death is dead and gone with the winter.
We will sing a new song.
Let hallelujahs flow like a river.
We're coming back to life.
We're reaching towards the light.
Your love is like springtime.
Come tend the soil.
Come tend the soil of my soul.
And like a garden, and like a garden, I will grow, grow.
Come tend the soil.
Come tend the soil of my soul.
And like a garden, and like a garden, I will grow, grow.
I will grow.
We will sing a new song because death is dead and gone with the winter.
We will sing a new song.
Let hallelujahs flow like a river.
We're coming back to life.
We're reaching towards the light.
We will sing a new song because death is dead and gone with the winter.
We will sing a new song.
Let hallelujahs flow like a river.
We're coming back to life.
We're reaching towards the light.
Your love is like springtime, like springtime, like springtime.
So this next song is called The Blessing.
And I don't know about you, but my life was a mess before Jesus.
I walked in darkness.
And I'm very thankful.
So as we sing out amen, I just want you to hopefully connect with that part of yourself that needs to cry out to Jesus.
Whether you're going through some good things or some bad things, that you would agree with God's heart here that he wants to bless you and keep you.
So please sing this out with me.
And when we sing amen, just let yourself go.
Let it be cathartic from your gut, you know.
Lord bless you and keep you.
Make his face shine upon you and be gracious to you.
Lord turn his face toward you and give you peace.
Amen.
Lord bless you and keep you.
Make his face shine upon you and be gracious to you.
Lord turn his face toward you and give you peace.
Amen.
May his favor be upon you and a thousand generations and your family and your children and your children and their children.
May his favor be upon you and a thousand generations and your family and your children and their children and their children.
May his presence go before you and behind you and beside you, all around you and within you.
He is with you. He is with you.
He is for you. He is for you.
He is for you.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
May His favor be upon you and a thousand generations,
and your family, and your children, and their children, and their children.
May His presence go before you and behind you and beside you,
all around you and within you.
He is with you. He is with you.
In the morning, in the evening, in your coming and your going,
in your weeping and rejoicing.
He is for you. He is for you.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
One last time.
Yes, God.
In this moment together,
where maybe you're bringing things to mind,
where maybe there are things weighing on us,
where it feels hard to say amen,
to rejoice.
Maybe we feel more close to the weeping side of things tonight.
But God, even there, I pray that your spirit would hold us fast.
Even there would we find you doing your still small work in our hearts,
teaching us to trust, teaching us to love beyond pain,
beyond rejection or beyond disability, God, beyond addiction or brokenness.
God, would we find you still pouring out your love,
still faithfully walking beside us,
centering us, guiding us through each storm.
And God, right now in this season of Lent,
we remember how you walked a hard road,
how you showed us the way of love,
love that doesn't give up even when there is pain,
even when there is rejection or sorrow, God.
God, your love did not run out.
Your forgiveness did not run short.
Would it meet us tonight?
Would it hold us fast?
In your name I pray, amen.
Thank you guys so much for spending this time together.
Brett's going to give us our message,
but would you guys just turn to the people around you as we transition?
Make them feel welcomed and at home.
Say hello if you haven't already, then we'll get started.
Well, grace and peace.
It is really, really good to be with you all.
My name is Brett. I'm the pastor here.
And it's just a joy, a joy to be with you.
And that includes those joining us online.
Y'all are not forgotten.
Welcome, and especially anyone who's new,
maybe here for the first few times and kind of feeling it out.
We're just, we're really, really glad that you're here.
Really glad. I hope you know you can just be yourself.
There's no need to, I don't know,
try to act holy or something more than you are.
You know, just like, just stay chill.
Just be yourself and know God loves you and we love you too.
We're really glad you're here.
So like Mindy just mentioned, we are in the season of Lent.
And for those unfamiliar,
that is the 40-day time of spiritual preparation.
As we approach Good Friday, that's the Day of the Cross,
and then on to Easter Sunday, which reminds me,
I should mention maybe a little bit of why we're meeting at 8 a.m.
Well, basically it's because we rent.
And so, you know, you don't get to choose that.
We'd like to meet here at 11 a.m.
That's when the other church is here.
So it was kind of either later or earlier.
And we tried finding some other places,
but we just couldn't find a place that we liked.
And if we meet outdoors, there's always the risk of weather, you know.
So after prayer and fasting, we just went ahead and chose 8 a.m.
I do hope you'll be able to join us, though.
So in this kind of Lenten season,
we are in a series right now called Lent, the Way of the Cross.
And we're just taking some time to reflect on the cross of Christ
and what it means.
And so the title of my message specific to tonight is
Christ the Substitute, Christ the Substitute.
And I should give a quick heads up.
I would say the last two weeks, maybe even beyond that,
but the last two weeks, I tend to do kind of a mixture of, like,
preaching and teaching.
When I think of preaching, I think of, like,
announcing the good news, the gospel of Jesus.
You know, and it tends to be a little emotional,
and there's, I don't know, some inspirational uplift at times
is kind of the name of that kind of style.
And then other times will be more like teaching.
So if you were here last week, you know, that was preaching.
That was intense.
I got some good feedback, though.
I'm glad it seemed to connect and resonate with a number of you.
That's great.
So I should mention tonight is going to be, like, a different vibe.
You know, it's going to be I'm putting on kind of my teaching hat.
And, you know, I probably slant a little more towards preaching,
but this is I think there's just times where we need to, like,
reflect on things and think things through.
You know, of course, much of Christian faith is really about the heart
and how we live and how we love.
But, you know, loving God with our mind, like, that is part of it.
And sometimes there's aspects of Christian faith.
There's maybe certain teachings or doctrines or things that either maybe
we go through a season where it rubs us the wrong way,
where it's just like, I don't know what to do with that.
Or maybe others in our life kind of have problems with it,
but then we don't really we can't make sense of it.
And, you know, there's just sort of I don't know,
there can be unease around certain theologies and things.
And that's true of the cross and certain ways of thinking about the cross.
So tonight's one of those nights where we just kind of like jump right in
to one of those topics that, you know, in kind of the well, it's one.
Well, let me back up a little bit. Let me start here.
There's a lot of ways to think about the cross.
We've been touching on a number of them throughout the series.
At times, these are called theories of the atonement,
which is very academic sounding.
I mean, anytime you use the word theory in relation to God, it's sort of strange.
It just basically means like, well, probably a better word would be like motif
or theme, approach, story, parable of the cross.
And what's interesting is we tend to, I don't know,
when we think of the cross, it's all sort of a jumble of like
all sorts of pictures and images and metaphors and ways of thinking of it,
you know, that are all kind of convoluted.
So it can be helpful to kind of parse them out a little bit
and start to think a little more clearly about some of them.
So there's like many different approaches to the cross.
The reason there's a lot of different approaches is mostly because the event
of the cross itself was, I mean, such a powerful, yes, traumatic,
but also powerful event for the early church.
And in many ways, mostly unforeseen, like who could have imagined that God
would in God's very self, in God's very son, go to the cross.
It was just like, oh my gosh, we cannot believe this.
So what it did was it sent generations of Christians back to their Bibles
to reflect afresh and anew to like, and by Bibles really for them,
the Old Testament, to reread it and to say, whoa, how, what was the meaning of this?
What was that all about?
And it's interesting that even the resurrected Jesus didn't like go into,
you know, all the details like, okay, so let me tell you, you know,
and like, and lay out some theory of the atonement or,
and there's no book of the cross where it's just clearly lined out
every question you could ever have.
And it's like a systematic theology of it.
It's just, that's not in Bible, right?
Like, of course there's various, as I'm naming, there's motifs and themes
and approaches, but Jesus himself didn't really give a lot.
Even like, if you think of the apostles' creed or some of the early creeds,
you know, just like Jesus died, why?
For sins.
And you're like, tell me more.
And it's like, well, that's all you need for sins.
You know, so like you can see where very early on it was kind of Christ died for sins,
you know, but of course we wanted to keep thinking it through,
like, well, explain it, unpack it.
Why for sins?
And, you know, I mean, you can kind of see where this goes.
So there's a lot of different approaches.
Like next week we'll be talking about the theme of Christ the victor.
This is where sin is like capitalized, and he is, well, in other words,
sin isn't just like individual misdeeds, like, oh, I messed up.
But sin's like this malevolent agency, this force, this power that's like opposed to God.
And so Christ in the cross is trampling that down, conquering sin, capital S, sin, evil,
everything opposed to God, right?
So that's like one way of thinking it.
In that approach to the cross, you can hear that we are more victims.
I mean, we are kind of victims of sin, of that, and like, yes, we align ourselves with that,
but Christ is saving us from sin, capital S, right?
So that's kind of a different motif, like a different way of thinking about it.
I should also mention these different ways aren't like contradictory.
It's not like, well, which one do you like?
Well, I only like that one.
No, it tends to be these kind of work together, but they kind of enrich the concept a lot.
Another kind of motif would be like the language, all the language of the blood of Jesus,
which I would be fascinated to like have a quick combo with each person
and like how that strikes them.
I mean, there's obviously lots of hymns that speak about the blood,
you know, washed in the blood of the Lamb,
and I don't know, maybe even preachers will say things like,
my name's been, or your name's been written in the Lamb's book of life with the blood of Christ.
You know, and this, for some people, it's kind of like, oh, that's so beautiful.
Others are just like, oh, you know, this is weird.
I don't know about all this, the blood, and wash me in the blood, you know?
Theologian Fleming Rutledge kind of, she has in her book,
I've mentioned her a few times in her wonderful book, The Crucifixion.
She kind of goes to bat for the blood, and she says, like, well, just keep in mind, it's poetry.
That's her approach, and I think she's right.
Like, it's not, I don't, I think we can take it overly literally, you know,
like as though Christians literally, like, yes, Lord, I hope I get to heaven
and I'm just bathed in the blood.
It's like, what on earth? No, no, it's poetry.
When we think of, what is blood a symbol of?
It's like the essence of life.
You know, so when we're saying, God, wash me in the blood,
or write my name with the blood, you know, it's this kind of, this motif.
So that's just another example, like another way of thinking about the cross.
But the one, none of that's what I'm preaching on tonight.
Long pramble, I better get going.
We're going to be here all night.
Long pramble, I know.
See, the teaching hat goes on, and we're just like,
oh, we're a little bit everywhere.
So what I want to talk about tonight is the way that Christ,
this language, how his life has been given for us.
And this leads us to the notion of the substitute.
Where, well, before I jump into the details, I'll just name,
this is probably the most, I'd say, controversial in modern times
kind of approach to the cross.
It's interesting.
It's very polarized.
Yeah, it's very polarizing.
For many in kind of more, I should say, conservative Christian circles,
this isn't just like one way among others to think of the cross.
This is the way to think of the cross.
And then you have kind of in more progressive Christian circles,
this is like the terrible way to think of the cross.
In ways, it becomes sort of a line in the sand.
So how do I know if I'm like a more conservative kind of theological Christian
or like a progressive?
And a lot of times it's this.
Like, well, do you believe in what's known as substitutionary atonement?
Do you believe Christ was the substitute dying for you?
And that's often where in people it gets very polarized.
Now, I know some of you I see heads nodding like you're in the loop.
Others are kind of like, I had no idea.
And that's fine.
If you're into theology and you read Christian blogs,
well then, oh my goodness, you'd be all into this topic.
It's an interesting one.
So tonight, I guess kind of where I want to take it,
I'm going to draw a lot from Fleming Rutledge for this one, this message.
I think she does a good job of helping us think this through.
And she kind of pulls from the good parts of everyone
and has some criticisms, critiques.
So I think she did a really good job of at least helping me think it through.
So hopefully, I can in turn do this for you.
So, all right.
So where are we?
What's up with this idea of Christ the substitute?
Where does it come from?
What's going on here?
A lot of the controversy stems from one Greek word, huper.
It's funny.
Isn't it how like one word can just send people in different directions
and like split churches and, you know, it's remarkable.
So the word huper, it means for, on behalf of, in place of.
You see this scattered all throughout the scriptures, both Old and New Testaments.
I'll give you a few examples.
Galatians 3.13, Christ redeemed us from the curse of the law
by becoming a curse for us, huper.
So you can see the language of the curse and then he becomes the curse,
takes on the curse for us.
The word is written, cursed is everyone who's hung on a pole.
Other translations say a tree.
Or 1 Peter 3.18.
This is actually, we touched on this last week.
For Christ also suffered once for sins, the righteous for the unrighteous.
So there it is again, right?
So Christ, the righteous one, suffering, dying for, on behalf of, or in place of.
This is where translators kind of have to make some decisions on how do they,
as you can see, they keep opting just for the word for,
which just leaves it a little more vague.
But it's that word, huper.
For the righteous, for the unrighteous, to bring you to God.
He was put to death in the body, but made alive in the spirit.
Here's from Isaiah 53, verses 5 through 6.
And this, obviously it's not the Greek word, because this is like Old Testament,
so written in Hebrew, different word.
But you can kind of hear the idea kind of rumbling around.
It says this, but he was pierced for, whose transgressions?
For our transgressions.
He was crushed for our iniquities.
The punishment that brought us peace was on him.
By his wounds we are healed.
We all, like sheep, have gone astray.
Each of us has turned to his own way, and the Lord has laid on him the iniquity of us all.
So you can see where this idea, where we get this idea of Christ as dying,
dying in some sense for us, on our behalf, in our place, as our substitute.
In just a moment, I'm going to get to some of the objections to this.
And you can maybe already see where what people start getting very nervous about
is sort of the image of God hovering in the background of this.
Because it's like, well, if that terrible thing happened to Jesus,
is the idea like, God wanted that terrible thing to happen to you.
But then he's like, okay, no, instead I'll punish my son.
So it's kind of here where people start getting nervous with this notion.
So I'm going to give you tonight three objections and then three sort of responses.
So if you're a note-taker, you can jot these down.
Objection number one, notions of Christ's substitution don't make sense
because an innocent person cannot take on the guilt of another.
That should be one kind of critique.
If you've ever been in church circles, you've heard maybe a preacher,
when they're preaching the gospel, they might give an example like this.
Imagine that you went to trial for a crime.
And it was a crime, indeed, you were guilty of.
And you go through the whole trial, and the jury goes back, they deliberate,
they come back, and the judge says, okay, what did you find?
And the jury announces you guilty.
And, in fact, they go even so far as to punish you to death.
But it's then, this is where preachers love this kind of stuff,
it's then that the judge stands up and says, no,
I will take the punishment on their behalf, in their place.
So that would be, and this is what Christ does,
steps in, the judge judged in our place.
Now, where this objection kind of pushes back is it says,
well, see, the only problem is that doesn't make any sense
because you can't do that.
Like a judge can't literally stand up and be like, hey, you know what?
I'm taking this one, I'm going to go to jail,
or I'm going to go to the electric chair, whatever, on your behalf, in your place.
They're like, well, you can't do that.
Christians cannot take on the guilt of other people.
So this is sort of one objection.
It's like, what, you can't take on guilt?
Like, no, my guilt's my own.
That's kind of the objection.
All right, second objection.
Notions of Christ's substitution are divine child abuse.
This one's, this is pretty, I'd say more powerful a critique than the first one.
So, okay, what does it mean?
Imagine like a very different revival meeting.
And here the preacher, you know, preaching the gospel,
and so they say, imagine that you sinned,
and your father became very, very angry.
So angry that his wrath was going to be poured out upon you.
But it's then that your noble older brother steps up and says,
no, dad, don't do it.
Hurt me instead.
I'll take the punishment so that they don't have to.
And then the preacher says, see, this, this is what Christ has done.
He has absorbed the wrath of the Father so that you wouldn't have to.
He's gone to the cross so that you don't have to.
And that's the good news of the gospel.
All right.
Can you hear where this starts to get problematic?
Like in kind of where people are getting real nervous.
Like, oh, gosh.
Again, you can kind of hear the image of God.
You can see it kind of happening there, you know.
And, in fact, this really we're coming back to the language of abuse.
You know, this gets problematic where this is how actually abusive households,
it can kind of play out is something like this,
where you might have like one spouse, you know,
like who is going to kind of distract the abusive one so they don't hurt the kids.
Or maybe there is like one of the kids has kind of learned how to like distract,
you know, drunk mom or dad to kind of take the abuse.
You know, so when you kind of start using this metaphor and then like, you know,
preaching it and so this is like this is where just people don't like this notion of,
you know, Christ as substitute.
All right.
Third objection.
Notions of Christ's substitution depict a vindictive God.
I think this is more making just naming clearly what the other two are already implying.
But Rutledge, he quotes a French writer, Antoine Vergote.
I don't know how to, I don't speak French.
Vergote, I have no idea.
He said this, Antoine said this,
can one imagine a more obsessional phantasm than that of a God who demands the torturing
of his own son to death as a satisfaction for his anger.
So you can hear where the critiques are coming from.
Playing around.
Yeah, these are, I think, some really powerful critiques.
So, okay, so what do we make of this?
On the one hand, you have kind of the scriptures are, you know,
I think it would be really challenging to argue that scriptures never are talking about
something like Christ the substitute.
But on the other hand, you have these objections, you know.
So I'm going to offer a few responses.
First, response number one.
Context is king.
And, you know, for example, I do think there would be something like really messed up,
in particular, with us, I don't know,
like I'm imagining someone who's teaching this kiddos in this older kids classroom
right over here right now, you know, standing up and saying,
kids, you know, have you ever lied to your parents?
You know, they're like, yeah.
Have you ever taken someone's toy?
Yeah.
Well, then you deserve the cross, you know.
But the good news is that Jesus went to the cross for it.
You can see where it's just so, like, kind of extreme, and, you know, it's just like,
I, the punishment doesn't fit the crime, I don't know.
And I would agree.
I think, yeah, this can become, like, sort of psychologically damaging, even for kids and stuff.
Like, sort of, you know, they get very scared of, like, Father God, you know,
and it's, yeah, there's something to this.
However, it was actually the psychologist and Christian writer Richard Beck,
and we did a whole series on one of his books, Unclean, a few months back.
And he has had quite an interesting journey with all this, with the cross,
and he teaches a weekly Bible study to some inmates outside of,
there's a prison outside, I think it's Abilene, where he lives.
And he, for years, he leans definitely towards the more progressive kind of wing of the church.
And so he really avoided, you know, Christ the substitute kind of stuff.
Just was like, I'm not going to go there, you know.
And so he did a lot of Christ the victor teaching
and would lean towards that in his interpretations and such when he's teaching inmates.
But one day, I think they were studying Isaiah 53, that passage we read earlier about, you know,
the Lord has laid on him the iniquity of us all.
We all, like sheep, have gone astray and, you know, all that.
So kind of going through it, and he started to talk about this idea of kind of Christ the substitute
because that passage just seemed to lend itself so much to it.
And he could tell just from, like, their body language, the tears in some of their eyes,
that it was beginning to resonate very, very powerfully with them.
And as he started to dialogue, because, of course, it was a Bible study, so it's, like, discussion-based.
As they started to talk, out came their stories.
And what these—in this prison it was men.
So what these men had done, things that they found simply unforgivable.
And they were struggling so mightily with guilt and with shame.
And so far from seeing in this a kind of, you know, oppressive thing,
they found it a beautiful picture of the gospel, that Christ had taken on that guilt,
had taken on that evil, had kind of absorbed it into his very being
and then went to the cross for them.
Even though it is—one way to think of it—it's a very, very strong metaphor, a strong picture.
It's, like, very intense, which is why I'd be very hesitant to have our folks doing lots of kids teaching on this.
Because that's where it's, like, a powerful metaphor.
But you could hear, even in my message last week, where when—because I don't think it's just, you know, prisoners—
we, too, at times, have done things that we feel are, like, unforgivable,
things we wouldn't share with anyone.
We don't, like—we're going to take it to our grave, kind of.
And we feel it's unforgivable.
And so, suddenly, this notion of Christ as our substitute, Christ dying for us, on behalf of us,
taking the punishment that we deserved, can become incredibly, incredibly liberating and helpful.
So, that's kind of the first response.
Context is everything.
You know, pre-K, Sunday school, class, is completely different than adults,
who have done adult things at times, and can be struggling with guilt and such.
Response number two.
We need a poetic ear and a flexible theological imagination, not one that's overly logical and wooden.
I'll just really quickly touch on this.
This is kind of a similar point as with the blood of Christ, where we've got to remember,
where God-talk is really challenging.
At some level, we are always describing realities where, ultimately, language will begin to break down and fail us.
I mean, if you ask me, like,
well, Brett, just explain to me clearly, what was happening in the cross?
Ultimately, what do I have?
I have a bunch of stories and metaphors.
I mean, even think of the way preachers preach it.
Like, I was doing some of them terrible metaphors.
But, you know, well, imagine it's like a judge, and there you are.
You know what I mean?
You can see where, what is that?
Are you saying, oh, literally, there's going to be a trial?
No, it's this.
It's a parable.
It's a story.
It's a metaphor to try to get us thinking.
You know what I mean?
It's sort of the old adage about the finger pointing to the moon is not the moon itself.
So all these ways of describing the cross are just trying to get at something quite unnameable.
I mean, ultimately, it's beyond words.
Whatever was happening in the cross, it's like words fail.
So we've got to remember, we need a kind of flexible theological imagination.
We need poetry.
We need words that are pointers to the truth.
While not getting overly hung up and literal-minded with these things.
You know, for example, I think that critique about human guilt.
Like, oh, this doesn't make sense.
Humans can't take on the guilt of another.
Like, that's where I think kind of the trap that that falls into.
Like, wait, I'm really trying to make this make complete, logical, human-level sense.
And it's sort of like, well, this is God we're talking about.
And God is not just like a human.
So I can't take on your guilt, but who's to say God couldn't?
So that's where we kind of need that flexible theological imagination.
Third response, and I'll close with this.
Trinitarian theology is absolutely essential.
And that's a big word, Trinitarian theology.
It just means this notion of God as Father, Son, Spirit, as loving relationship itself.
And you'll recall the second critique was about divine child abuse.
And one of the problems, often how this has been preached in really dangerous, messed-up ways,
is to make it sound like God the Father and God the Son are kind of, I don't know, against each other or something.
You know, where it's like, God the Father's all angry.
He's like, well, I need someone to vent my wrath on.
And then Jesus is like, okay, I guess it'll be me.
He's like, yeah, it'll be you.
It gets so weird.
And that's just a completely terrible metaphor in a way to think of the cross of Christ.
What's happening in this notion of Christ as substitute?
It's really the idea of God giving God's self on our behalf in our place.
It's not like the Father and the Son kind of at odds.
It's Jesus with one will, willing with one will what the Father wills.
It's Christ.
It's God the Father, Son, Spirit entering into the cross.
And that's where there's a book called The Crucified God by Juergen Moltmann,
which really pushes this idea to its extremes.
Because some theologians have even tried to kind of parse it out like, well, no, it was only like God the Son.
There's only a part of God that really went to the cross.
And really, I think the truth is this is God giving God's self.
And that changes.
I think that completely changes the metaphor.
It completely changes the way we think about this.
The way I might sum it up is this.
The notion of Christ as our substitute was not originally intended to be a picture of an angry, bloodthirsty deity venting his wrath upon his son.
It was a picture of God's self-sacrificial love for us and all creation.
I would say that's the heart of this.
But at the end of the day, there are many ways to think of the cross.
And so if you find yourself just in a place where you're just like, I can't do it, you have a place at the table.
And if you're like, oh, man, I love this notion of Christ the substitute, you have a place at the table.
And I think the church has been divided far too long on topics like this that the truth is we can come to the table as God's children,
even in the midst of our agreements and our disagreements and everything in between.
So I really look forward to hearing about your meetup discussions this week and how everyone's able to process all this.
Because I do. I hope it'll foster some good conversation.
So as we come to the table of the Lord tonight, as we take in the body of Christ in the bread, the blood of Christ in the wine,
it's a moment where we get to connect afresh and anew with Jesus Christ who promised to be present to us in this moment.
I mean, at some level, always, but in a really special way.
There is something unique and powerful about this moment where we come to the table of the Lord.
So I encourage you, if there's anything in your heart tonight where something in you wants to connect with Jesus,
then I encourage you to to come forward and participate with us tonight.
We practice what's called an open table. So if you're here tonight and you want to participate, you're free to do that.
Having said that, if you're not in a place to do that, that's perfectly fine.
There's no like stigma or judgment or something if you don't come forward.
So the way we'll do this, we're going to just form kind of one line right here.
And we tend to start folks at the front and we'll just kind of work our way back.
The red cups are actual wine and the white is grape juice, if that's a concern for you.
So let me invite you forward. This is the table, not of the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love him and for those who want to love him more.
So come, you who have much faith and you who have little, you who have been here often and you who have not been here long,
you who have tried to follow and you who have failed.
Come, because it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites you.
And it's his will that those who want to meet him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
We're going to close with a hymn called The Love of God.
It's one of my very favorites.
And I hope that as we go through these lyrics, especially after what Brett has shared, I hope that you will just let them sink in.
It reminds me of a lot of what Brett shared last week, just that there's nothing that can escape his love, his forgiveness.
He went to the ends of darkness for us, and his blood has covered everything.
So if you guys would like to stand and sing this, or if you would like to sit and reflect, either one is completely appropriate.
The love of God is greater far than tongue or pen.
Can't ever tell.
It goes beyond the highest star and reaches to the lowest town.
The guilty pen bowed down with him.
God gave his son to win.
His erring child he reconciled and pardoned from his sin.
Oh, love of God, how rich and pure, how measureless and strong.
When years of time shall pass away and earthly thrones and kingdoms fall,
When men who hear refuse to pray on rocks and hills and mountains cold,
God's love so sure, self still endure, all measureless and strong,
Redeeming grace to earth embrace the saints' and angels' song.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Could we with ink the ocean fill and wear the skies of parchment clay
Where every stalk on earth a quill and every man a scribe by trade
To write the love of God above would drain the ocean dry
Nor could the scroll contain the whole, though stretched from sky to sky
Oh, love of God, how rich and pure, how measureless and strong
It shall forevermore endure the saints' and angels' song
The saints' and angels' song
I'm so glad you were here tonight. I hope that the words, the music,
the message, the people give you joy and nourishment in the week ahead.
Don't forget our meetups, our meeting in the coming weeks.
We would love to have each and every one of you be a part of one.
These are the cards that are out there on the table.
Fill one out, check the box for meetups, put it in the box.
If you would like prayer or just someone to talk to,
I would love to be that for you tonight.
Come and find me and we can talk.
Lastly, I would love to send you off into your week ahead with a benediction.
So if you are comfortable, you can stand to your feet,
just in a posture of receiving.
Put your hands out if you like.
I do believe these words are true for each and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with its yet-to-be-determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go with the assurance that you are loved, you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the reminder to extend these same gifts of love and grace and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with this week.
You are loved.
Be blessed.
We hope to see you back here next Sunday.
Good night.
The Saints' and Angels' song
O love of God, how rich and pure
How measureless and strong
It shall forevermore endure
The Saints' and Angels' song